mr. Muller come to the last Salaam
alaikum peace be with you I may be your
host you're watching the Dane show
that's right and thank you for tuning in
i'm d'lai we got a great exciting
program for you today we got not only
what we're gonna do something different
I'm gonna take it outside of the intro
studio and not only do we have one two
three but four exciting guests for you
that's right for the more the merrier so
we come back not only we have Jon look
mine Musa Jeremiah we got a former
Christian Catholic former atheist and
they're here to share their story so we
could all benefit that's right we gotta
go and talk with them take you to the
session with them and then hopefully God
well you can benefit you can benefit and
learn so much from their experiences
we'll be right back don't go anywhere
for this week's exciting show stay tuned
this is the
this is the theme you know this is the
days of the angels
this is the video this is the
hamdulillah it's a blessing and a treat
today that we have not only one but we
got three and then one inshallah God
willing we'll be arriving soon
so let's get right into it for those
that don't know about the Deen show
please at the end come get one of the
cards and you can get our website here
you can follow us on the Twitter like us
on the Facebook and keep up with all of
our updates and our programs so we have
John look mine and shake Musab sound
legal like a month Thank You brothers
I'm honored to have you guys to be with
you so let's get right into it people
want to know they're here
you know why with all of the negative
stereotypes all of the misconceptions
about Islam people think that people
would be running away from Islam but we
have a former atheist we have two former
Catholic Christians and their Muslim now
they've chosen to submit not to the
creation but to the crater tell us a
little about yourself let's start from
the my from the right coming down to the
to the left go ahead please assalamu
alaikum everybody my name is luke maan
and so I st. already introduced me you
already know a little bit about me so
what was the question again
Oh briefly about myself okay so I'm a
former atheist I just moved to Chicago I
took my Shahada a little bit more than a
year ago actually in China and Beijing
China and so how brief exactly that's
good okay
was this I mean I could go on forever
but he said I wanna go it
my name is Musa suger pond I was born
and raised in San Diego California I've
been I became Muslim back in 1998 my
parents are from the Philippines and I
was raised in the Catholic family but
again I became Muslim back in 1998
Salaam alaikum
so my name is John Smith and I was born
and raised Catholic you know I did the
baptized confirmed and did everything
like that but then I uh I took my
Shahada in October of 2012 here at UIC
I'm the Alexi campus and you know it's
it really it really started with uh I
took I took a class here at UIC and I
had been searching for religion
searching for truth higher truth it's
not a higher purpose in my life or
something like that for awhile and I
took a class here at UIC and I really it
was a sociology religion class I've been
stuck studying sociology for the past
ten years and and I and but in this
class our professor would come in and he
would talk about you know being at
church and enjoying the sermon and and
and I and I Denver realized that like
you could be a scientist and a believer
at the same time so so actually taking
that class and seeing my professor come
in and talk about his faith actually
inspired me to realize that that you
know science and religion aren't
mutually exclusive let that I could be a
social scientist and a believer at the
same time so we have uh we have our
fourth panelist Salt Lake oh please
introduce yourself for audience
my name is Jeremiah VI I'm an assistant
professor here at UIC in the department
thank you all for being with us so we
got for now hum did in love what a treat
for and let's get it you mentioned
Shahada now not only for the people that
are here alhamdulillah assume people be
watching us all over the globe and some
people are like okay because there's a
lot of
not yet Muslims dozen people don't know
about Islam so everybody has the
potential to submit to the crater not to
create they hear this word she had the
shape can you tell us what what does
this mean when one takes the Shahada
mashallah the the Shahada literally
means a test of a testimony and
Islamically it's referring to the test
application of faith it is the first
pillar of Islam as Islam has five
pillars but the first and foremost of
those five pillars is the Shahada
again the testa fication of faith now
Shahada it comes from an Arabic word
which means to see to witness share it
to Shaytan I saw something but one of
the unique things about the Shahada it's
a test offical of your belief in Allah
in your belief of the one god although
we've never seen God but we say this
word Shahada a shadow la ilaha illaallah
which is our bear witness that I have
witnessed literally I bear witness that
I have with that I bear witness in the
oneness of God even though we've never
seen God and there's an indication here
that your faith should be even more
powerful and stronger than what you see
with your eyes that when God has
revealed something that that takes
precedence
even over our senses and the things that
we might know with our mind on our
intellect and most of the time anyways
the commandments are in accordance and
there you can reconcile it with things
of logic but at the end of the day faith
is something which is unseen and when
you say the Shahada although it
literally means to see we've never seen
God but we believe in that and there's
an indication there that what we believe
is even stronger than what we see with
our eyes and the second part of the
Shahada is to testify that Muhammad is
the Messenger of God so again even
though we've never met Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him we testify
that he is a messenger so we can clearly
say that we agree to worship nothing not
a stick that a stone at a bone at a man
at a woman but the creator of all these
things that's it that's correct
period hamdullah so everybody's agreed
to that doctor can you tell us professor
what fascinated you about Islam please
tell us first let me apologize for being
late sorry for that I think I think I
start to become
I'm actually in church as a as a kid
probably around 8 or 9 years old so like
we used to be in church a lot like we
belong to what they call holy rollers so
you go to church like many many days a
week you spend a lot of hours there so
during the time that I was in church I
used to spend a lot of time reading the
Old Testament because there's a book in
the Old Testament that's named after
prophet Jeremiah
who I was named after and so I read a
lot about the Old Testament and reading
about the Old Testament the prophets of
the Old Testament it seemed like to be
this big discontinuity between the Old
Testament and the New Testament excuse
me so I think my first like
understanding of what Islam was what
really grabbed me was that it was
continuous like from the prophets
alayhim as-salam from those prophets in
the Old Testament all the way to Mohamed
Salah by using let's go with look man
and Moosa I tell us you have some unique
names tell us now what made you choose
these names and tell us about the people
that you're named after let's start with
you look mom please yes so um actually I
love most Chinese Americans I didn't
actually have a Western name I was never
given a Western egg you see like Chinese
Americans on campus they got names like
you know Jake and Steve and Dave right
actually I went was my Chinese name my
whole life it's Lu Mong which actually
literally translates as long road
spelled Lu ma n so actually what
happened was when I when I was in Africa
I was in I was in Ghana Africa I noticed
that actually there were a lot of
African men that had the same name as me
and so their day their names were Luke
maan and so I actually actually at my
mentor dr. Muhammad Amin actually he
kind of introduced me to his long and so
I open up the Quran and I noticed that
the 31st chapter of the Holy Quran was
named Luke maan it was it was my name
but with the Q in it so I mean I you
know I listen to a lot of Tupac Shakur
when I was in college you know I mean
forefront Tupac Shakur started listening
to to Malcolm X and after hearing
Malcolm that's a story I mean I I just
really wanted to take my Shahada um my
name is moose
but my legal name is actually Edwin the
next thing y'all see me you can say
shake Edwin right but like any kind of
but um Musa is the Arabic name for Moses
man it's named after the prophet Moses
may peace and blessings be upon him how
did I get that name the night I took my
Shahada we went back to a friend of
Mines place and he had a poster on his
wall the family tree of the prophets so
I had lineage as we know that the
prophets you know from Adam to Noah to
Abraham Jacob Yousef or Joseph and Jesus
and Muhammad peace be upon all of them
they all come from the same lineage so
they had this family tree with all these
different names and he also had a poster
of the 99 names of God the 99 attributes
of Allah and they told me basically you
know you should try to pick a name now
an Arabic name that you can go by in the
Muslim community so you can either pick
Abdul something or you can pick a name
of a prophet these are like really good
names so my cousin was trying to get me
to pick Abdul Ali and so it was actually
between Abdul Ali and Musa and Masha
Allah Allah put in my heart that I
wanted to select this name Musa which is
after the prophet Moses and taking the
names of the prophets is a virtuous
thing as you can hope to take on their
qualities and the prophet's alaihi salam
peace and blessings be upon the prophet
mohammed he said name your kids with the
names of the prophets so it's a good
thing to tame yourself after prophets in
hopes to follow their way
you when I embrace the slam from that
day on I knew I never wanted to drink
another drink in my life I never wanted
a smoke I never wanted to harm my body
because I realized that it was a
blessing you know to be able to see life
from the perspective of Islam because
it's like a lens that clarifies life for
you and so I started seeing the clarity
of life and I said this is what I've
been looking for all my life now all I
have to do is live up to it read some
things what he watched each show the
dicho but tell us John moving along tell
us a little bit about your past life you
mentioned that you were also involved in
the past in the history you hummed along
now you're you're you're looking into a
tree great heights getting your PhD but
we all you know go through the things
that now we learn from we gain
experiences and you've actually you were
former gang member
okay so you were also Catholic were you
practicing Christianity at that time so
I want to see we want to see what was
the contrast of what you used to believe
before and how did you was Catholicism
was that something that was a regular
part of your life because obviously it's
like you know opposite you know you'll
still see some gangbangers that wear the
cross and still you know do maybe some
shootings but the was that did you wear
the cross it when you were doing like
drive-bys
I took you know I I did wear a cross and
it was a it was a cross and there was a
thread a handmade cross and it was the
colors of the game that I wore so would
you consider yourself religious
spiritual at that time uh and you know
it our gang had our own prayer or you
know the gang I was in I don't want to
mention the name
it's a Chicago game and we had our own
prayer and we had our own literature in
our own our own way of believing our own
things to believe in yet yet at the same
time everyone it predominantly was from
a Catholic or a Christian background you
know so so there was like a mixing of
you know Christianity with with with you
know a belief in the game itself you
know but um but but yeah I wasn't I
wouldn't say that I was I was very
religious at the time I mean I was I was
raised Catholic and I was born and
raised yet I was born into the religion
you know and and I went to a Catholic
school for eight years but it was in
between that it was in that summer in
between eighth grade and ninth grade
ninth grade year whenever I was
recruited into the game you know I was
13 years old and you know at 13 you know
you don't know much you know and so um
so no I just kind of um I became a
flower you know and and and it wasn't
until you know uh you know ten or so
years later you know I'm getting older
I'm nineteen twenty years old you know
and I'm still on the street still
gangbang and still doing this type of
stuff you know and and and actually one
of my other friends who was in the same
gang
he sat me down he was like you know you
I think he was getting ready to go off
to the military himself and he and he
was like you know you could either you
could either continue to be in the gang
and continue to wear their colors and
and let you know follow these other
people basically continue to be a
follower or you could go off and start
your own you know thing and you know do
your own thing be a leader you know and
start your own life and so at that point
that's what I did and and so I didn't
get out of the game because you never
really get out of gangs but um was like
blood in blood out the most part yeah
yeah and and uh and so I didn't get out
but i but I stopped I stopped going
around you know and I stopped hanging
out with these guys you know and I kind
of started to do my own thing and uh you
know got interested in school and
education and stuff like that so how did
you why didn't you just stick with what
your parents were from the Catholic
background what made you what fascinated
you about Islam
well Islam didn't come around until you
know so so you know I for the past I say
for the past ten or so years I've kind
of been religious list you know I've uh
or even even closer to you and kind of
like a pagan I would say you know the
the Sun in the moon was the God and the
goddess and there was this equality
thing going on you know in my mind and
and so uh yeah so it's been had been a
quite a while you know since I had
practiced any kind of Christian beliefs
or anything like that but um and so the
way it all the way I came to assign me
it was so strange you know my mom always
told me that uh you know God works in
mysterious ways you know and and
Michelle ie is like how I came to Islam
was was so strange I started off I just
started a I bought a MacBook you know
and I had access to iTunes and I was
like oh okay and on iTunes was the
iTunes radio and I started listening to
that side tune radio and I found a
classical Persian music on there and I
was like wow this is really good stuff
so I started listening to this and I
would leave it on every night you know I
kind of leave it out while I slept and
then the one thing led to another I was
I cannot want to see some YouTube video
I want to see someone playing these
instruments so I typed and you know this
this music on YouTube but in the
suggested video section was like
lectures for like Chamizal Yusef you
know and these other lecturers and so I
was like well you know I clicked on the
suggested videos area and so I started
listening to these lectures you know
along with still listening to the music
you know and then and and somehow or
another I ended up on a calligraphy
website and I was looking you know it
was this strange like series of events
that happened that led me to Islam and
that's why I say you know like I didn't
really the event is how how I chose
Islam I don't feel like I chose Islam
but this but Allah chose me to be a
believer instead you know and and of
course I had to profess my belief in
Allah and
and in his oneness in the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him but I eat I
didn't choose to be a Muslim you know I
love toast for me to be a Muslim and so
and so this is really strange I was
looking at this pill agree for your
website and and I seen calligraphy it
was in Farsi and it wasn't Arabic and I
didn't know the difference between the
two but I liked what it looked like and
I had no idea what it said I just liked
how it looked like and and and so I
saved the image and I put it on my
desktop you know and and several months
go by and I'm an intro to sociology
class I'm a TA there you know and it's
300 students in the class and uh and
this one young brother walked up to me
and he was about to ask me a question
about class and so he seen my desktop
and he was like are you Muslim bro and I
was like no but and I'm kind of
interested in it you know and they
completely spaced out his question for
class and he just started going into
like talking about Islam and talking
about the MSA here on campus and there's
all kinds of Muslims here on campus and
you know that I should get involved and
stuff like that and uh and I asked him I
was like what is I was like what made
you ask me that and he said he's looked
at my desktop and I said it was the
Shahada on my desktop and I had no idea
what it was I was just drawn to this
image for some reason I was drawn to
these to these words you know and and
and after that like you know it was
history I contacted the MSA I had no
idea what an MSA what even was you know
I contacted the MSA here I can't just
some brothers from the MSA and and and
and before long you know within you know
within a couple weeks of that brother
coming up to me and asking me if I was a
Muslim I had taken the Shahada here in
our in our campus library masha'Allah
alhamdulillah tell us a professor when
you see Islam we know that Islam is sent
as a mercy to the world it's a peaceful
way of life you know calling him and
being at peace with their creator peace
with themselves and peace with humanity
but when you see it malign the way it is
through the media and the
misrepresentation of it you know Fox
news etc how does this make you feel
actually I started having these
conversations with friends
probably the week of 9/11
I think 9/11 was like on a Tuesday and
like that Friday we went to Juma one of
my good friends he's uh his Egyptian he
told me now I understand what it's like
to be black I was like wow just three
days it's all it took so like the way
that I look at what Muslim what Muslims
are going through is just a continuation
of what other groups that have gone
through that came to America so I I
don't really put a lot of stock into the
like the sentiment that they don't like
us because of our religion like I think
it's the same old bigotry racism
prejudice that African Americans they
they had we had to deal with the Jewish
community Irish people Chinese
immigrants that helped build the West
the Mexicans indigenous people that were
here so I don't I don't think that is um
that different so I think the challenge
for us as Muslims is one we have to
recognize that and the second thing we
need to do is we need to look at what
other people have done that made it
easier for us to practice Islam today
and a lot of them were not Muslims and
the third thing that we need to do is
like make sure that if we see oppression
like other people in society that we do
something about that and I think you
will see that there are natural allies
in America people who are not even
interested in Islam that want to make
sure that we can practice our religion
masha'Allah John tell us I'm sorry look
ma look ma tell us what have been some
of the challenges after something Islam
that you faced actually I'm actually
very surprised cuz it wasn't that
challenging it wasn't that challenging I
lot of people complain about how their
families are not really understanding of
their of their Shahada
but in Ch you know masha'Allah my family
has been very supportive and actually it
was at the transition for it was
actually pretty natural for me because
you know I'm a racial minority and you
know Muslims had at least in America
there's a history of Islam actually
standing up against racism so that was
that was a very natural transition for
me and also
within the Muslim community most a lot
of us are immigrants you know and I
myself I was born in China I'm an
immigrant too so actually I just just
you know Muslims stand up for
immigration rights you know and so I
mean those two things being an immigrant
and being a racial minority actually
made the transition very easy for me as
a chinese-american and I agree I really
like what John said masha'Allah about
how actually uh I didn't choose this
long Allah subhana WA Ta'ala chose me so
I mean I I felt like I really connected
to what you said because actually you
know who opens up the Quran and sees
their name you know I mean I feel like I
felt like that a lot definitely had a
plan you know I mean it's it was just
beyond my control so certainly you know
whatever happens is all part of the
creator's plan masha'Allah Sheikh Musa
tell us now for the viewing audience
that not yet Muslims there Handy's
Arabic words and I heard one of them
Allah can you go ahead and describe when
we talking about loss or someone things
like the Sun is the moon God maybe some
foreign god that you're talking about
describe what do we when we say Allah
what do we mean when we say the word
Allah Allah it basically is the Arabic
word for the one true God with a capital
G right so it's the most beautiful name
of God and we may use words and we'll
try to be a little bit better about that
maybe using some non Arabic words for
the viewing audience inshallah
but otherwise Allah it's the it's the
one God that every prophet came and
preached about so if it's Spanish or
Tagalog you might say Jose if it's
English you'll say God and if it's
Arabic you say Allah so Allah is not a
moon god it's not a you know a statue or
it's not in a desert god or a camel or
something like that Allah forbid right
but it is the the way and the word that
is used in the Arabic language for the
one true God which is why you'll also
find Christians who are Arab Christians
they also say Allah and they believe in
Allah because Allah means God so we use
Allah because Arabic is the
the language that you know for universal
language that bonds all of us together
otherwise it does mean that once you got
now you as has fallen the way of Jesus
Musa Moses they all submitted to the one
God there were all Muslims so they
weren't submitting to the creation but
to the crater and you chosen to do that
you chosen to be a Muslim following the
path of all these messengers that came
so tell us now what were some of the
challenges that you faced you accepted
back in 98 correct you've obviously had
a lot of experience and since then is
there any that you had to share with us
that we could benefit from yeah I mean
subhanAllah I was one of those who did
go through some challenges right it
wasn't always easy but the biggest
challenge that I faced was not
necessarily from the community because
what society because it was still pre
9/11 but it was for my family Filipinos
are very tight-knit family very
family-oriented so this was very
threatening to them and they had a lot
of fear that perhaps this would cause a
rift and break up our family so my
mother and my father before we even
became Muslim they were very much
against the thought that we would
convert our religion and it became a
family affair because my brother my
elder brother by about 18 months a year
and a half older than myself and my
cousin all of us were learning about
Islam so it became a family affair it
wasn't something just myself was going
through but aunts and uncles got
involved why were you why were you
learning about Islam now this is where
it all kind of happens I mean you know
long story short I was a freshman at the
University right and it's at that time
when you're I was about 19 years old
your mind starts maturing you know
intellectually you start wanting to know
the why behind things and as opposed to
just accepting things for what they are
so I started to question my first fight
my first semester actually I had a
philosophy class and the first five
weeks of that class was about heaven and
hell and you know and about Jesus peace
and blessings be upon him and you know
we were raised to believe in heaven and
hell and Hereafter but we never really
thought about it it was always me to
appear like it was mythology
like a bedtime story you know but um at
that point my professor said imagine
having
everything that you ever desired all of
your pleasures fulfilled for all of
eternity and that's heaven now imagine
putting your hand on the stove that pain
that you feel on your hand and pose upon
all of your body for all of eternity and
that's hell so you know I believed in it
but I never thought about it like that
and at that moment it started become
kind of real and I thought to myself at
that point that if there's a heaven I
know if there's a heaven that's where I
want to go and if there's a hell I don't
want to go there and one thing led to
another I also got exposed to is la m--
I'm going to give you the short version
got exposed to Islam and I thought it
was interesting of all the world
religions I was the only one that made
sense to me um but I didn't know any
Muslims it's not like I wanted to become
a Muslim
and it wasn't until I actually met a
Muslim who was also Filipino brother
that was a convert from the Bay Area his
name was Eugene we didn't know he was
Muslim but he started hanging out with
our group and there were some things
which were different about him and you
know he was he had a clean life and one
day we were in a conversation and he had
different views on things so one of my
friends I think it was ask him one night
that you know what denomination are you
because I don't think you're Catholic
then he said he was a Muslim he said he
was a Muslim and it really caught us you
know it took us back I mean
surprised us caught us off-guard and
then I had learned about Islam and I
thought it was interesting but here he
is Muslim and he has you know a nice
perspective on things so he got close
with us and one of my best friends he
ended up getting really close to him he
took his shot harder first and about two
months after that my brother took his
Shahada and a day after my brother took
Shahada my cousin took Shahada so
whereas before I didn't know any Muslims
even though I thought it was interesting
now I'm in a carload of Muslims okay and
they're all talking about Allah and
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
so it was right there in my face and I
started actually I don't know if it was
arrogance or pride but you know when I
started feeling left out that here they
are doing this new lifestyle adopting
this new lifestyle and I'm still doing
my thing so I started playing like the
devil's advocate
and I actually started arguing you know
with them about Islam and questioning
everything and I said to myself you know
and if they're going to be good Muslims
on become a good Catholic and I started
practicing things that I'm you know that
they were saying we should do but we
didn't necessarily learn we were
supposed to do but we knew it was good
and I tried to practice like them but as
a Catholic um but it got to the point
one night when my brother came up to me
and he asked do you believe in the
things that we say and I said yeah and
then yeah do you believe Jesus is God I
said no and he said then what's holding
you back and I gave him some foolish
answer that I don't even remember what I
said I was just trying to justify and I
honestly I can't even tell you what I
said because I don't remember what I
said my brother looked at me confused
and just walked away and said whatever
man
but I went to bed that night and I told
myself tomorrow I go to the one become
Muslim right so this is how it you know
it would became a family affair because
my brother he was already Muslim for
about two months at that point and my
cousin and we had actually had to kind
of conceal it we weren't openly weren't
open about our Islam at that point we're
still kind of telling our family were in
a learning stage and it was very very
difficult for them again because family
is very tight-knit it was about keeping
the family together and that's how I
became a family affair it's it was
actually first my brother abu bakr and
in my custody my cousin isa who had now
reached out to me and one of my best
friends mahmoud yehia the three of them
as well as eugene who is omar right so
they all mashaallah word i guess you can
say the main influences on me and
eventually accepting it but the
challenge I faced was with family but by
Allah's grace you know it was a fear
that they had and as time passed they
openly accepted as being Muslim because
he saw it brought our family closer
together so the brother who read Quran
it talks about how you have to honor
your parents so we tried to honor them
more we tried to serve them more and it
brought our family closer together if
anything and we tried to serve them more
and they were completely accepting of
our faith now and hamdulillah and they
even take their Shahada masha'Allah
masha'Allah alhamdulillah don't panic
now that was half of the interview we're
out of time next week we'll be back for
more god-willing
so until then you stay good be good and
follow us on the Facebook or it goes the
opposite way actually is the Twitter
that you follow and the like is on the
Facebook that's right and share our
shows please don't be shy go ahead and
share with a colleague with a friend and
let people be enlightened like these
brothers were and sisters out there
we've done so many programs and what's
the point if we make them but it doesn't
get to the people so it needs to get to
the people so we need your support
share our programs out there with the
world so more people can benefit and you
can get the reward inshallah God willing
and help us to grow this program so more
people can benefit from it from the work
and God willing we can all increase and
goodness we'll see you next time for the
rest of their interview with these four
fabulous brothers on the show until then
peace be with you